lilly Reinhardt has a message for body
shamers inside Katie and Orlando's
24-hour romp Plus The Bachelorette is
back and Becca's ex Ari is still causing
drama hey friends how was everybody's
long weekend the daily Deni is back in
the week just started but guys love is
in the air who watched The Bachelorette
last night and don't at me because
everybody watches it but first we've got
new photos of Katy Perry and Orlando
Bloom who took a quick jaunt to London
Katy is in the middle of her witness
World Tour but not even that can keep
her away from her man guys she flew from
Belgium to London where they were
snapped in and matching motorcycle
helmets for a quickie 24-hour hook up
because apparently long distance is not
a thing when you can afford to follow
each other around the world but you know
what it's nice to see Katy in Orlando
going strong that's where the future a
source tells us Orlando is ready to
settle down they are talking about a
future wedding but they are taking it
slow and have it press the subject of
kids now speaking of kids one Riverdale
star is shutting down pregnancy rumors
and body shamers and one fell swoop it
all started when an unflattering photo
of Lilly Reinhardt sparked rumors now
the actress was expecting a child with
boyfriend Cole Sprouse now Lilly took to
Instagram story on Memorial Day with
this clap back nope
not pregnant adding this is just my body
and sometimes I'm bloated
sometimes I go through periods of time
where I gain weight 21 year old actress
continued with a body-positive message
for her followers quote my body is
something that I will never apologize
for my body will constantly go through
change as so will yours I don't know
about you guys but I think it's annoying
Lilly even had to say something about it
to begin with but you know what it is a
message a lot of young women need to
hear and what I love most about it is
that this isn't the first time Lilly has
been unapologetic about keeping it real
she previously opened up about her own
battle with depression I've never had
any problem telling anyone
that I've struggled with it and so when
people started to like receive what I
was saying and saying that there were
they were responding to me just even
talking about and be open about it I was
like oh yeah let's keep talking about it
then good on Lilly there but we are
switching gears now to talk about
Bachelorette Becca Cooper ins second
chance at love her season of The
Bachelorette premiered last night and as
always the first night was filled with
some studs and duds which means I had to
bring in our bachelor queen and host of
roses and rose' our very own lauren zima
oh my gosh I am on a Bachelorette hi I
haven't slept because of all the studs
and duds I love that has a lot going on
of course people can watch your
wine-soaked recap of last night's
Bachelorette premiere all roses and rose
a but I want to get your initial
impression right now yes starting with
who had the best limo bit I don't you
know who had the best bit out of the
limo
well I'm night one it's all about being
both genuine and memorable right which
is not easy to do I gotta give it to
Garrett Garrett showed up in a minivan
moment and he says I've got this minivan
because I'm ready to be a good husband
and a good dad okay Garrett and guess
what guys he got the first impression
rose
that was a good first impression sweet
up throws a little weird like get in my
minivan i'ma show you the soccer balls
in our future there's no windows um
green think had the most awkward first
impression poor Joe right you guys
probably saw this going viral grocery
store Joe he was so sweet had this great
package he owned his own grocery store
that's a real job well produce yes
wonder I was a social media participant
ID 'el um but Joe just got so nervous
that he couldn't say anything to her and
he got sent home so hopefully we'll see
him on paradise Chris Harrison teased on
Twitter really well there still is a lot
of potential there but who do you think
is an early favorite to win the whole
thing
when Becca's loved oh well yeah I was
really glad that ABC full-on
acknowledged this during the premiere
they brought back some former
bachelorettes who acknowledge that for
many recent seasons the guy who gets the
first impression rose is the guy who
gets picked in the end so that guy might
be taking a ride in that minivan I might
be wrong
yes Garrett's got the first impression
rose and Becca said she was smitten with
him
I also think we need to look out for
Blake because she said that she and him
were on the same wavelength I think
there's a difference that you got to
watch for in the language she might say
oh that guy has a great personality but
that doesn't mean she's connecting with
that great personality with Blake she
said she just felt like she knew him so
I'm watching Garrett I'm watching Blake
I also think clay and Colton Colton both
football player I loved the confetti
thing that was cute memorable they seem
like nice guys okay while you're here
though we also talked about Becca's ex
re like I can't believe we're still
talking about that long on-camera
breakup remember the one if I must
discuss it I will I'm referring to him
as he was shall not be me well you guys
know that remember that on-camera
breakup at the end of last season of The
Bachelor felt really long producer says
it was an unedited and he's seen a
different story yeah I think what we're
learning in this new GQ interview with
Ari is what Ari's definition of editing
is because he was on the view last week
and he said the finale was edited and
the finale was always touted as being
the first in franchise history an
unedited breakup I actually asked Becca
about that on Wednesday she said oh no
no no it was definitely unedited and
then in GQ Ari is saying well it was
edited because what you didn't see was
off-camera producers were standing very
close to me and kind of giving me advice
on what to do in the same accent that's
called the reality show right I don't
think I mean I think of editing as
editing of the footage like video
editing
he's claims that he felt 100% betrayed
by the show I mean it's one thing after
the other I think it's dangerous to
consider people who are using you're not
using you but you're part of their job
you know and it's tough because I think
on the one hand you get close with these
people and they're friends but on the
other hand they got a job to do and ari
did acknowledge that he said I know they
have a job to do but then he also said
he felt 100% betrayed so well as Lauren
mentioned she did get Becca's reaction
to this take a look are you saying that
the breakup with you guys was edited and
even though everyone's saying it's not
out of it no it was definitely unedited
I mean let's be honest I would not you
know if it wasn't an edited I edited I
would want the snot off my feet I feel
like the mascara off my foreheads like
that was all real I loved her comment
there because as she
was saying if it was edited you know she
maybe would have asked for a little
Photoshop as well Michael wake up paying
a little bit you know but guys get their
gets this there's even more re drama the
GQ profile was called the most hated
bachelor explains himself and it also
claims that re cut the interview short
yes
so gqueues Rebecca Nelson she spent two
days with Ari and with his new fiance
Lauren Burnham the one whom he dumped
his fiance Becca for so this is the
second fiance in matter months but
anyway um and she says things were all
Welland and II accept and then she asked
a certain question that seemed to kind
of upset Lauren and Ari texted her
saying that the interview had felt
tabloid II the whole time and that it
was over he said quote I agreed to do
this because I believed it would be
positive and shed light on Who I am
and in no way that I want to make Lauren
upset I think our interview is done so
Ari wanted to cancel his planned
photoshoot with the magazine and
decision see mm-hmm yeah and Lauren even
spoke out after the interview dropped
she took to Twitter writing about the
reporter quote she crossed a line nobody
should have to feel bullied in their own
home I mean fair but I do have a
question for you do you think this is
the last we hear from Ari I mean I feel
like it's one thing after the other one
yeah you know he announced his wedding
date right before Becca's premiere and
now he's doing a new interview with GQ I
think the problem is that Ari keeps
trying to say I'm a nice guy I'm a nice
guy but keeps kind of tripping I'm all
over that I don't think this will be the
last that we'll hear from him but if I
were him I would see why I brought
Lauren in you guys she has all the tea
and so much more up at roses and row
rows a weekly recaps here on e t--'s
youtube channel and of course facebook
watch Thank You Lauren and thank you
guys for watching stick around with
those plenty more daily Denny tomorrow
all right bye